[Music]
We're here to talk about real time
conversational video uh with Pipecat.
That's me, and with Tavis, that's Brian.
We'll introduce ourselves a little bit
more, but in the interest of keeping it
moving, let's talk about what we're here
for. If anybody Have any of you ever
seen one of these robot concierge
things? Do they work? No, they don't.
They're terrible, right? Um, it's
actually possible nowadays to build this
kind of thing, but actually good. Um,
it's a little bit tricky, but that's
what we're here to show you how to do.
Um, there are three things you need to
think about when you want to build real-
time AI. Um, the first is your models.
Obviously, we all know what models are.
That's why we're here at this
conference. Um, the thing that you don't
necessarily know you need to think about
is your orchestration layer. We're going
to talk a little bit about that. And
then of course you need to deploy these
bots somewhere. That's the third step,
deployment. Talk about that as well.
So step one, models. I come from a
little bit more of a traditional, it's
funny to say that voice AI world where
the traditional pipeline people talk
about is speech to text, so
transcription, right? And then LLMs for
your inference and then text to speech,
right? Like that's the typical kind of
cascading pipelining here. Sure enough,
people are nowadays are using some
voicetovoice models. That is a use case
for this kind of thing, but there are
reasons sometimes you might use one or
the other. Um, real-time video is a lot
more complicated. Doesn't have to be,
but it can be. And I think Brian will
tell you that it should be. Um, there's
a lot more stuff you need to think about
to do video generation in real time.
So, Brian, you want to tell us a little
bit about Tavis and how y'all are
thinking about this? Thanks, Chad. So,
Tabith started out as a as a AI research
company and we started off with a uh
single model that was like a rendering
model. What we quickly realized is that
we need to be able to put this into a
real-time context for it to be useful.
So, it needs to be fast. And once we did
that, we started realizing there's a lot
of missing there are a lot of missing
pieces. Things like turn detection,
response timing, uh picking up signals
and orchestration. And uh we started off
in in the beginning we didn't know about
Pipcat when we first built it. Uh but
we've been partnering with Pipcat over
the last year and it's come to our
realization that like a lot of the stuff
Pipcat does is going to be very
important for conversational AI and
making it real. Um I think we can go to
the next one. Yep. Uh we have a demo.
You can go to our site tavis.io. I was
going to do it live but for the sake of
time just check it out. You can go check
it out on our website tavvis.io.
and I'll hand it back. Well, no, there's
one more thing. Yep. So, uh, what we do
at Tavis now is we offer a
conversational video interface. It is a
endto-end pipeline that allows you to
have a conversation with a replica of
anyone. You can create your own replica
of yourself. You can put it online and
you can have a conversation. The
response time is around 600
milliseconds, but that's not ideal
because a lot of times that's too fast.
Um, so we have to slow that down
sometimes based upon some of these
models that we're using. Um, and there
are a lot of steps that go into this.
You can see there's like uh we're like
like Chad talked about the the basic
layers of a conversational stack, but
we've also have we also have these
proprietary models, Sparrow Zero and
Raven Zero that we've created which is
kind of like our IP or what we're
offering and we're going to right now we
offer those in our stack but we're
moving towards a world where we're going
to offer those in things like Pipad.
So models and we'll come back to the
Tavis models in a little bit and how
they are getting better and some of the
cool new things that are coming from
Tavis that you will want to use. Um
orchestration is where my my world steps
in. So that's that's Pipecat. That's a
thing on my water bottle and my shirt
and my jacket and all that kind of
stuff. Um let's talk a little bit about
what Pipecat is. Um there's a really
interesting phrase on Brian's slide,
real time observability and control into
the flow of a conversation. Um, that's a
a lot of those are words that you that
that don't really mean anything until
you actually go build one of these
things. And when you build it, the first
time you use it, you go, "Wow, this is
amazing. This is great." And then as you
start to actually think about what it's
going to mean to have that in
production, you realize, oh, wait, there
are a lot of like boring infrastructure
kinds of things that we need to solve.
The ability to understand like to to
have observability into how the bot is
behaving and why it's behaving that way.
the ability to get capture metrics on
things and understand things like
sometimes the bot takes a long time to
respond. I wonder why that is. Well, it
turns out there's a whole lot of these
kinds of things that you need for a real
live production app for a real live
production bot that you need something
like Pipecat. Pipcat is an open source
framework. Uh it's built by my company
but is open source and actually fully
vendor neutral and it's designed to be
this orchestration layer for real time
AI. And by that I mean you are you you
have a user that is going to be
producing either video and or audio and
you want to also be delivering video and
or audio to that user and you want to do
that with as low latency as possible.
That's the real time part of this whole
conversation. Um if you went to the AI
engineer website and you saw the little
button on the bottom right that says
talk to AIE, uh that's powered by
Pipecat. It's actually using the Gemini
live model. So, it's using a
voice-tovoice model, but there's still
so much other stuff you have to do to go
from voicetovoice demo bot on the web to
like like in your browser or on the web
to an actual like shipping production
app that even Google themselves, even
the Gemini documentation says you can go
use our own like tools and our, you
know, like our our browser tools and
things to experiment with Gemini
Multimodal Live, but when you want to
take it to production, you do need
something like Pipcat to actually
orchestrate what's happening in your
entire app.
Um, I'm going to try to do this side
very quickly and there there are a few
QR codes coming up. So, now would be a
good time to uh get those buttons ready.
Um,
Pipcat itself, two lists of three that
you need to think about to understand
what Pycat does. The first one is
something I just kind of already talked
about. Um, the three things that Pycat
is doing for you is handling input. it's
handling the processing and the output.
Input is receiving media from your user.
So, in the case of a traditional voice
bot, that's just voice. Um, in the case
of a of a Tavis replica, that's sending
voice. And they even they're doing some
interesting things that we'll talk about
with inputting your user's video and
allowing a Tavis replica to respond to
not only what it's hearing in the voice,
but what it's seeing in the video coming
from the user. Um, getting into that,
that's the processing part. That's step
two. That's where that's where
essentially you're going to run through
a bunch of different models. Uh in some
cases, you can do almost all of what you
need with a single model. Um in the case
of like Gemini multimodal live for voice
or a Tavis replica, they there there is
a way that you use Tavis inside a Pipcat
bot where you can basically let Tavis
kind of do everything for you. Um run
kind of as just one integrated piece. Um
and then of course all of those models
hopefully this is supposed to be
real-time and interactive video.
Hopefully, those models are producing
some kind of output that you want to
show to your user. That's the video and
the audio being produced by your tools.
In a typical voicebot, that is, you
know, that is uh text to speech that is
being played out as audio. It might also
be things like UI updates if you're in a
web app that you're pushing UI updates,
that kind of thing. And of course, in
the Tavis case, it's video and audio
that are hopefully presented in a way
where the video stays synchronized to
the audio, for example. That's a really,
really hard thing to do well depending
on exactly how you build this whole
thing. The three fundamental pieces of
the of Pipcat that enable those things
to work are frames, processors, and
pipelines. Um, pipecat's name comes from
the fact that it is about building a
pipeline. Um, and a pipeline is
comprised or is composed of processors.
Processors are things that handle
frames. Frames are essentially any it's
basically a type container for a kind of
data. So in a pipecat pipeline, you will
see a whole bunch of frames with things
like little snippets of user audio like
10 or 20 milliseconds of audio comes
across as an audio frame or video frames
from the user's camera device you can
capture. But even things like uh voice
activity detection VAD comes across as a
user started speaking frame in pipecat.
All of those frames progress through a
series of processors and a processor
just takes in some frames and outputs
other frames. So a good example would be
like the LLM processor for example is
taking in frames that are essentially
context frame like completed context
turns from the user in the bot and it is
outputting a stream of text frames. So,
so if you're capturing streaming output
from your LLM in Piput, that looks like
a bunch of text frames coming out of
that processor and all those are put
together in a pipeline. And the pipeline
is how you describe what you want your
bot to do. And the idea behind how
Pipcat runs your pipeline is that it's
doing all of that stuff asynchronously
and doing its best to minimize the
latency of every piece of information as
it goes through the pipeline. So, there
is a a much better and longer
explanation. I know that that was a lot.
Um, there's a much better and longer
explanation in the Pipcat docs. That is
that QA file in terms of what it
actually looks like. It was going to be
a little tight to try to get in and do
some live coding during 15 minutes. Um,
but this is a QR code that links to this
example file. There's so much stuff in
the Pipcat repo that shows you this. But
just to step through these pieces real
quick, at the top there's the transport
input. This is the core pipeline inside
this bot file. And this is actually the
one of the Tavis examples that we have
in the repo. First thing is transport
input. That's where the frames come in
from your media transport. So whether
it's web RTC or websockets or Twilio
websockets or anything like that, frames
start pouring in from the transport
input. They go to a speechto text
processor. Um that's where transcription
is happening. So for example, one thing
that frame processor is doing is it's
collecting snippets of audio at you know
a frame at a time 20 milliseconds at a
time but it is sort of up to your
transcription processor whatever that is
deep gram or whisper running on
something or whatever to exactly collect
a bunch of frames collect however many
frames it needs to then output a snippet
of transcription information right so
that happens in speechtoext from there
we go into something called the context
aggregator that's because the
transcription or the the ST processor
is emitting transcriptions whenever it
feels like it. So we use other frames in
the pipeline that have made their way
through to understand okay the user has
started talking the user's microphone
has you know microphone level has
dropped so it looks like the user has
stopped talking maybe now is a good time
to group all of the various pieces of
transcription we've gotten over the past
few seconds together and emit a single
context aggregation frame that's what
triggers the LLM to run and so we we we
grab the context and if you you know of
course if you've programmed with LLMs
you know you get the context with all
the array of messages and the tools and
everything you shove that to the LLM and
then starts streaming tokens back. Those
tokens come out of LLM as text frames as
well as there's like a start and end
frame. And if you if you're familiar
with this approach, you can probably see
all these other frames as they start to
exist in here. But then TTS essentially
accumulates those and generates speech.
This bot file is actually an older
example that uses an older Tavis model
where we were actually generating audio
and then we were sending the audio over
I believe a websocket. It's not
important. We were sending audio to a
Tavis model that was generating the
video based on the audio and then
sending back to us back to Pipecat audio
and video. So essentially the same audio
but synchronized with the video. Those
come as a different series of frames
that then go out the transport output
and that is again essentially the same
transport that we're using on the import
side input side but this is the output
side. And so that's where all that media
goes back to the other user. And so you
can you can start to see how with this
structure um it looks very simple right
here but it is incredibly powerful when
you realize that you can kind of put
anything you want in this pipeline. Uh
we have people for example that like
there's a construct in Pipcat called
parallel pipelines. And so we have
people that have this exact same
workflow, but at the same time in real
time, they're running another LLM that
is doing things like um you know,
sentiment analysis or we have there
there's there's one uh Pycat user I
talked to that is using Gemini live
multimodal to detect if the person
answering the phone is a person or if
it's a voicemail greeting. But they have
a separate they have separate pipelines
running for whether it's a voicemail or
whether it's a human. And all that
happens in Pipcat through the use of a
parallel pipeline. Run one model to
determine and then it sends a signal to
the back to the pipeline to say do the
voicemail branch or do the human branch.
So you can start to get a get an idea of
what you can build. Even if you have a
model like Tavis that is doing 90% of
the hard work of making the actual
interaction feel good, there's just
enough other stuff that's going to
happen around the periphery that it just
makes a lot of sense to wrap what you're
doing inside something like Pipecap.
This is what so Brian showed a picture.
This is that same Tavis avatar. Um if
you go to the QR code on the last slide
um which is going to come up again in a
second. Um you can basically run that
example like you need to you sign up for
Tavis. You get a key you drop a key in
there. You run that example code
unmodified and it will pop up this UI
where you can both talk to that avatar
in real time, talk to the replica in
real time, but also you can see some of
like the interesting guts of what's
happening inside Pipcat in that debug
panel over there.
So you want to tell us a little bit
about why this architecture is
interesting and what we can do in the
near future with it? Yeah, so as I
mentioned when we first built Tavvis's
conversational video video interface, we
built it ourselves because we didn't
know about Bitcat. So we've spent the
last year learning a lot of the lessons
that Pipcat has already solved. There
are a ton of orchestration
aggregation
communication
functionalities that are in Pipcat
already that are going to basically save
you months of time. I mean it's going to
save you a lot of time. So um when we
first talked about having this talk I
was like we're not using Pipcat
internally. I was like, I I can't really
say we're using an alternative, but the
thing is our customers that have come to
us that are enterprise customers,
they're using Pipcat and they want to be
able to use our stuff in Pipcat. So now
we're we're getting ready to move our
best models into Pipcat. We've already
moved uh Phoenix, which is our rendering
model, but we're also going to be moving
turn taking, response timing, perception
models, things like that. And eventually
we're going to made up and actually
bring Pipcat internally as well because
it I spent like the last couple days
actually de debugging a problem that
Pipe gets already solved really well and
I don't want to have to do that anymore.
Uh yeah, so I talked about these models
that are coming. So we we we have a
couple different uh unique models. Our
turn detection model is a multilingual
model that determines when a person is
done speaking. You wouldn't believe how
important that is in a conversational
AI. It's going to make your AI faster
and it's going to make it so it doesn't
interrupt people simultaneously.
If you if you have a very fast uh uh
conversational pipeline, oftentimes it
will actually talk over the user. But
and if you have a slow one, it will take
so long to respond that people be like,
"Is it broken?" You want to get the best
of both worlds and that's what turn
detection does. We're also working on a
response timing uh model right now. And
that response timing, we're bringing all
these to Pipecat soon. That response
timing model will determine how quickly
it should respond even though the
person's done because if I'm telling you
about my my grandmother who's like going
into into a home and she's sad, you're
not going to want to like quickly
respond to that. You you want to think
and take your time, right? But if we're
having a chitchat, you want to be fast.
So that's what that's all about. Then
finally, our multimodal perception is
able to look at emotions, look at the
surroundings, what the person's wearing,
and also we'll be feeding that into the
turn taking and the response timing so
that we're we're able to provide much
more nuanced conversational flow. So
those things are coming to
so and so this is another example. Um I
will tear through the last because we're
we are already out of time and that's my
fault. This is another example showing
essentially a different way that you can
integrate Tavis into Pipecat and this is
part of the flexibility as they develop
new models. They're going to be things
that will run directly inside Tavis.
There are things that you want to have a
little bit of control and so you just
drop them into into a slightly
differently shaped pipeline and you can
get your bot to actually do what you
want to do. Um I will talk about step
three which is deployment extremely
quickly. Um there are a lot of different
ways that you can ship these bots.
Pipecat is I sometimes I call it open
source to a fault. I wish it had a
little a few more opinions on some
things. Um, really what you need is kind
of two pieces. You need some kind of
REST API to essentially to allow your
app, whatever your client app is, you
need some kind of basic REST API to tell
your app that that a user wants to talk
to a bot. And when that happens, you
need something to relatively quickly
spin up a new instance of your bot and
connect it to that user. And this is
what essentially that's showing here.
Um, and then you also need a thing we
haven't talked about. Again, go read the
docs is the transport layer. That's the
that's the hopefully WebRTC part that
actually moves the media back and forth.
That's part of what your infrastructure
is configuring. You have a user that
wants to use a bot, you need a you need
an API that can start a bot and and
connect that bot to your user. the very
short version of how if you want to just
solve this problem with a little bit of
money, come talk to us at our booth
because pipecat cloud is like if you
don't want to mess with Kubernetes and
all that kind of stuff, if Kubernetes
makes you we used to have this thing in
Heroku where it would replace Kubernetes
with scare quotes around it and the
Heroku Slack which was fun. um come to
this talk. This is Mark uh one of my
colleagues talking a lot more about
Pipcat cloud and how we solve the
problems of deploying bots at scale and
how you can either use Pipat cloud but
if you want to actually just do it
yourself this is where you can learn how
to do that and that's our time. Thank
you'all very much.
[Music]